but rebel you clearly went for it you
posted this picture of a
a very serious injury it does look
slightly like
your nipple has slipped out but that
that's
okay no basically with
and we did all this crazy dangerous
stuff but basically that injury in that
photo
happened the day after we finished
filming when i left
i was very safely dance but then what
happened is i had to go to the beach to
take some hot photos for instagram
this is not every day you're in mexico
so i went
and then a freak wave came up
and knocked my friend's handbag into the
ocean that had a passport in her wallet
so i went running in like baywatch style
to save the handbag
and i got hit against the rocks so that
injury that you can see
is i got all scraped down my left hand
side and all bruised ribs
um so basically and protected me and
like we were totally fine even though we
did the most dangerous things
but taking the hot instagram photos on
the beach was um
my downfall were you able to at least
get the passport
yeah we got the passport and we like put
paper towel in between their pages
and it was fine survival expert there
you go